good afternoon I'm Jean Cummings and
welcome to the show we're here today
with Tom Frank author of the book the
wrecking crew how conservatives rule
this is his second book he also wrote
what's the matter with Kansas Tom thank
you for coming in that's my pleasure
Jean well you have had quite a change in
stature since your first book came out
if that book was promised on on the
working class folks in Kansas who were
seemed to be voting against their
economic interests because Republicans
had shoved the agenda toward social
issues such as abortion and gay marriage
and that book really struck a chord with
the Democratic Party and you've become
something of a policy guru and sort of a
party shrink for them these days come on
how do you feel well of course it did I
actually should mention I mean there's
no reason you would know this I had two
books before what's the matter with
Kansas I was the editor of a small
literary magazine published out of
Chicago I used to write about
advertising you know and yes it was an
enormous surprise it was a book let me
just say you know take a step back the
the what's the matter with Kansas was
about the phenomenon of working-class
conservatism there's a lot of people
have written about this including some
of my heroes
Christopher lash for example and and
Anthony I'm sorry I'm forgetting what's
the book about Boston the busing riots
you know the one I'm talking about it's
one of the greatest like works of
political reportage ever and I'm Anthony
Lucas that was his name but another
anyhow these were books that I had and
authors that I had admired for years and
I wanted to you know to try my hand at
the same subject and it was and it was
just a matter of chance that it became a
you know that it was the the culture
wars just dominated 2000 it wasn't a
matter of chance the culture wars always
you know are going to dominate unless
the Democrats do something to stop it
but I'm not a guru for the Democratic
Party they you know it did strike a
nerve though with many of them they
gobbled it up and felt like you had hit
something that they had not paid
attention to that's good I'm always glad
to hear that
but but like people don't call me and
ask now why did I was curious because I
saw your previous books largely about
marketing and then this your what's the
matter with Kansas in your book today
are in the political Shona and you said
you wanted to try your hand at that why
but what sent you in this dress well
when I was in college and in graduate
school we all sort of assumed that the
that the real power in society was in
the culture and it was in that you know
well I don't want to say the coat that
the culture wars were really important
because that would imply that I think
you know the war on Christmas is over
you know a really big deal or you know
those ten commandments mine so it's not
like that it was that we I you know we
prioritized culture we thought culture
was you know this supremely important
topic and you know I studied American
culture in graduate school and politics
had been sort of hived off into its own
discipline political science to write
about a political history was considered
that was that was a almost an antique
sort of calling and and you know a very
boring kind of I mean there's some
people who do it really well but it
wasn't it wasn't sexy right what was
sexy was to write about you know punk
rock and stuff like that so that's what
I did and and somewhere along the line I
changed my mind you know politics is
immensely important and so I sort of
went back to my roots as it were you
know talking about writing and thinking
about politics this is something that I
had been interested in as a young man
now there are Barack Obama got himself
in some trouble recently by talking
about how some working-class people can
feel bitter he used the word tried to
explain what he meant later and there's
some who felt like his line of thinking
when he came up with that expression was
derived in some way from your analysis
your work did you see that connection
and have you ever even talked to him
about what you're thinking is mmm well
he was my state senator when I
Chicago and so I met him but I didn't
certainly didn't talk to them about that
and I've given a lot of presentations
about the book and it's I believe he has
you know I think he came to one of them
I think he left early though I think he
was that interested well but look
bitterness there there's there's two
things about that famous comment first
of all to deny that there is bitterness
out there and the Heartland is is folly
of course there is I mean it just it
takes that ten seconds on the phone to
figure that out you know or go out there
and drive around in Kansas sometimes
people are pissed off you know that's
that's the case everywhere I mean
everywhere you go in small-town America
are working-class America you know
whenever you get out of Washington DC
you know New York City access this is
what you discover people are very angry
but the argument that I made he I the
reason I don't I mean I don't know if he
was thinking had me in mind or not I had
me in mind or not I really have no way
of knowing my argument was not that
people cling to their guns out of
bitterness the argument or whatever I
don't remember what some the other
things he said it was like they go to
church or because they're bitter or they
and they oppose trade deals because
they're bitter I actually oppose the
trade deals myself I think they're
really stupid and I think it's very
rational for working-class people to
oppose those trade deals the problem is
that neither party is giving them what
they want you know neither party is
speaking to that urge but my argument
was not that these were expressions of
bitterness but that they were
expressions of of class that what the
the culture wars have come to substitute
for it sort of the traditional language
of class so you have this new class you
know we're in the old you know language
of American politics you had you know
the the vested interests or the
malefactors of great wealth or you had
the robber barons this kind of thing and
they were you know pulling the strings
in Washington and you know that American
politics or liberal politics anyway
revolved around this kind of antagonism
between the common people and
you know powerful interests defined by
you know money industry that's who you
know and what the culture wars have done
is substitute for that sort of healthy
natural form of class antagonism the
culture wars have substituted a
different class enemy liberals right
liberals want to take your gun away
liberals want to wreck down the ten
commandments monument liberals put this
filth on your TV set so you where your
kids can see it you know liberals are
having this from the war against
Christmas all you know right down the
list liberals the intellectuals are the
real class enemy and these two are
always conflated and they call them
liberal elitists and they you know they
drink lattes and they drive Volvos and
whatever the hell it is and they all
have college degrees and went to fancy
schools and so that's what I wrote about
in the book is it was the effort to
redirect the language of class towards
this this this new enemy the
intellectual the liberal well but so
that so that it's kind of a it's a
misunderstanding of what I what I was
talking about but you know that's the
way it goes you know in politics people
you know they blab much like I'm doing
right now just let their mouth run you
know alright well let's talk about your
new book
now tell us what your aim was with your
new book the your premise here okay so
what happened was after the I wrote most
of what's the matter with Kansas when I
lived in Chicago and and also wrote it
at my dad's house in Kansas City and
then I moved to write before I finished
it I moved to Washington and that was in
2003 and I really hadn't spent much time
in Washington since the 1980s back when
I was a you know college student and the
first thing that astonished me about the
city was how rich it was and the second
thing was how many scandals there were
you know in O 4 it really started after
the Abramoff affair that broke in early
a 4 but nobody really paid any attention
to it till O 5 and after that it was
like like a dam bursting you know it's
just one thing after
after another after another I mean just
what was it last week two weeks ago that
Senator Ted Stevens got indicted a few
days before that you had the business
with the politicized you know
politicization of the Department of
Justice you know a little while before
that you have the business with the
Federal Aviation Administration you know
and there's stuff just one thing after
another after another and I'm and I'm
and I'm reading this in the newspaper
and saying what is going on here you
know what what explains this this tidal
wave of corruption but it's not just
corruption there's also the other two
things that you notice here are this
sort of fantastic misgovernment you know
epic incompetence at you know all across
the federal government and in you know
certain remarkable ways I referred
earlier to the Federal Aviation
Administration but all these agencies
essentially being run regulatory
agencies being run in the interests of
the regulated industry which is a you
know bizarre thing when you think about
it and then the third thing is the
massive outsourcing the contracting out
privatizing of federal operations which
is really the signature gesture of the
Bush administration and what I came to
understand after studying these three
phenomena is that they are all in some
way together that they're linked they're
all three expressions of the same way of
looking at the world and that is well
the short answer is just to say
conservatism but that's not fair for a
number of reasons that the slightly
longer and more correct answer is the
way of looking at the world that gives
rise to all these things is the way that
understands the free market as being
like the ideal nexus of human society
and that understands government as an
imposition and as a you know as a
corrupt entity by its very nature and we
see that even the people who call
themselves conservatives are the main
bearers of this ideology and you also
argue in the book that conservatives
want government
to be incompetent and intentionally try
to make it so so that the free market
would be then invited in to take these
contracts to take over government
functioning because they in their belief
think that the free market system is
superior as you say yeah to what they
believe it's a when you when you put it
that way it sounds so improbable and
unlikely and yet there I came across in
my research an essay from 1928 I think
it was back in the you know the Coolidge
administration or something and it was
written by a former president of the
Chamber of Commerce at the US Chamber of
Commerce which is one of them still to
this day one of the biggest players here
in DC in terms of you know the lobbying
and that sort of thing and the president
of the Chamber of Commerce back then in
1928 wrote this essay or was interviewed
they interviewed him and called it an
essay and he had this immortal line
where he said that um what is it the
best public servant is the worst one and
then he went on to explain what he meant
by this idea the best public servant is
the worst one you don't want good
talented people in public service
because then they'll you know they'll do
things right and they'll persuade the
public that the government works and
then the people will trust the
government and the next thing you know
you know it's a slippery slope to
communism you know and and he you know
he it's also you know if you have good
public servants they'll meddle in the
affairs of private enterprise and all
this sort of things so the the interests
of business are to keep good you know
the best and the brightest out of
government and I was pretty shocked when
I came across this and what's even more
shocking is that you find that same idea
not in exactly the same terms but the
same idea reiterated down through the
history of American conservative
thinking you know lots of people argue
this this isn't just one zany dude in
1928 this is like this is this is a
widely held view and you can follow all
the way through that's right a
Republican revolution of 94 because a
former Speaker Gingrich would lose
of the incompetence of government and
and the bureaucrats in particular oh
yeah that's that's that's the other side
of the coin as they you know this
constant denunciation of bureaucrats
President Reagan was sort of a champion
at that and then you remember I don't
know if you're if you remember some of
these guys like you remember Donald
Devine who he appointed to be the head
of the Office of Personnel Management I
mean the they had a very antagonistic
attitude towards federal workforce and I
mean I'm sort of getting away from the
subject here but that sends out that you
know this constant abuse heaped on
federal workers by their bosses Gingrich
Reagan whoever you know what kind of
message does that send to the sort of
people that used to come and work for
the government well you know if you're
hated and despised and your boss wishes
you would go away yeah you know you're
not gonna go work for the federal
government you know you're gonna go do
something else with your life and that
the you back in the 80s this was all
kind of shocking and remember and a lot
of people wrote about it I mean it's
it's all happening again now under the
Bush administration but it's not as
shocking because we've been through it
once already and so you see a lot less
written about it but back in the 80s
when this was all new and fresh and they
would do studies of how federal
employees felt about it you know about
you know being abused in this way and
and they felt really bad about it I
remember one study a guy he was trying
to stick up for federal workers in the
mid-80s and he said look you know you
it's it's customary to you know denounce
bureaucrats and talk about how awful
they are but the fact is you know these
people look at here's one way of
measuring there their level of
accomplishment they've won I think it's
six Nobel prizes in Nobel prizes for
health you know since in the last twenty
years or whatever it was at the time
that was like 86 so I think he was
counting from 1968 or something like
that and I went back and looked up those
Nobel Prizes and they were yes indeed
won by all sorts of employees of the
federal government you know people that
you would never think of like someone at
a VA hospital or someone at the National
Institute
of health or something like that made
won a nobel prize for medicine well if
you go from when he wrote that essay up
until now
say how many US federal government
employees have won the Nobel Prize in
medicine it's a single guy now you break
the book up into two parts
you have the insurgents and then you
have saboteurs tell us about the two
parts and why you broke it up in that
way all right I'm gonna drink some water
first if you don't mind absolutely water
is okay the the first part of the book
insurgents is about the the conservative
movement outside government but still
here in Washington it's a the book is
about conservatism in Washington as
opposed to say conservatism in a place
like Kansas you know which is a
completely different animal and what I
discovered when I studied the
conservative movement in Washington is
that it can you can describe it as a
movement that you can also describe it
quite accurately as an industry and you
know it has all these different ways of
making a profit it's in some ways it's
politics for profit but you know it's
sort of started with Direct Mail back in
the 1970s this discovery by certain
people on the right most of them living
in the suburbs of Northern Virginia
which is by the way where they still
most of the industry conservatism is
still headquartered there but they
discover that they can make a lot of
money with these kind of frightening
letters advancing whatever you know
cause of the extreme right sent out by
the million to average Americans all
over the country you remember things
like the Panama Canal giveaway this was
a great this is a great little money
raising idea I never really did anything
to stop the legislation but you know it
was a but there's numerous things like
that all sorts of issues that you could
raise money with and then you find the
movement advancing on to doing other
things like for example essentially
selling its services to industry to go
after the left because the left
you know costs business money you know
if they get their laws enacted or or
whatever it happens to be it's expensive
for industry so you know selling
themselves to industry as you know
soldiers you know to engage in the
political war and then you find this
sort of what I thought was the most
amazing efflorescence of industry
conservatism which was sort of came from
the iran-contra affair you remember when
oliver north and a bunch of other people
but oliver north is the one that we most
remember for it we're trying to sort of
build this mechanism for use it for you
know for running foreign policy that was
completely outside of government they
would raise money privately for the
Contras or they would do it by selling
government property remember that sold
weapons to iran our enemy i'd always
sort of struck me as anyhow i was you
know anyhow that's what the first part
of the book is about ok the second part
of the book is about what happens when
you put this when you take this very
extremely this buccaneering
entrepreneurial attitude and apply it to
government put these people in charge of
this state what happens then and the
title you know saboteurs that's that's
what you get and that they the the link
between them and said that i thought
when i was reading it is it the first
part of the book explains how they they
came together in terms of their thinking
and their philosophy and fine-tuning it
with various different campaigns but
then the what bubbled out from backing
freedom fighters and fighting communism
and all these other causes was the
market that the market is the answer to
really
governing yeah and that so that then as
you take us into the second part of the
book we arrived closer to current time
and in the Bush administration with the
no bid contract
and the privatization of so much of
government work and then you raise
questions to illuminate how effective
that has been yeah well that's the that
is the question of our age by the way
that I should take a step back here and
we were talking about my other books and
everything that I've worked on in the
past and it's throughout all of them
there runs a theme and that is to
scrutinize the market I mean we live in
a time when the market I went to the
University of Chicago for graduate
school the market is is regarded almost
as as God or if not God as certainly as
an infallible force of nature you know
something that always works in these
very particular ways and we can
understand it it's you know through
science and and this is just so much you
know rubbish in my opinion and so what's
what's fascinating to me is to see these
people least real true believers in the
market and in the market religion trying
to enact and actually doing it in acting
you know forcing their market eyes
division of government on our US federal
government and what's the you know
what's the results of that and you
mentioned outsourcing and privatizing
and I think we said earlier this is the
the initiative for which the Bush
administration will always be known that
it is the federal government has the
money I'm sorry let me try to get my my
facts straight here the federal
government has grown enormous ly in
terms of like expenditures during the
Bush administration but its workforce
has not grown which is amazing fact so
where's all the new money going well
it's going to contractors and that's
what you know with all three of the Bush
administration's great sort of the
things that it has done and cleanup from
Katrina Iraq reconstruction and the
Department of Homeland Security all of
these have been they've done they've
used this model to try to accomplish all
three of these things this free market
privatized outsourced model and in each
case it's just been this you know
gold-plated botch justice
you know disaster now in when you're
leading up to your second part about
them actually governing with this
philosophy in the first section you
spend a lot of time on South Africa and
the Angolan rebel Jonas Savimbi yeah
yeah now I have to admit when I got to
those sections it took me a while to
figure out where you were going with
that so so why spend so much time in
Pretoria a little bit about lessons from
it's it's it's interesting one of the
there's I tried to tell this story the
story of applying you know market
principles to government I tried to use
a bunch of different narrative devices
to tell the story and you'll remember
one of them is I I described the housing
in Washington DC you know another one
was I was I followed the career of Jack
Abramoff that we mentioned him earlier
that was sort of the first scandal that
I became aware of here in DC and and
still two to date the biggest scandal of
the last five years I think I mean
correct me if I'm wrong maybe it's you
know it's just to see the enormous mess
and I I got very interested in this you
know where'd this guy come from how did
he you know how did he get into this
position and so I started doing research
on on Jack Abramoff career by which I
mean you know I a lot more than just
doing the LexisNexis thing I went into
the Library of Congress in red the sort
of magazines of the extreme right way
back in the early 80s and this guy was
he was all over the place he was very
much a true believer he wasn't just an
opportunist or a crook or something like
that he was I mean he defined true
believer he was the clear-eyed young man
and so I and that's that's fascinating
to me that this guy who was such an
ideologue became you know such a
corruption estándar to see how that
happened so I was following his career
and it his career you know we started
off or first came to public attention as
the national chairman of the College
Republicans and I used to get I to be a
college Republican oddly enough but
that's that's neither here nor there so
we're not gonna go into that Frontera
different era and actually it wasn't it
was 1983 it was a he was he was the
national chairman at the time but I
didn't get very involved in it I was
sort of repulsed by the whole thing
right away and I gave up on it but I was
recently back home in Kansas City and I
found my College Republicans badge in a
drawer the button that you would wear on
your lapel anyhow so after he did that
he you know following this guy's career
he you know he interacts with all the
other sort of big-name men of the right
of that era and one of the stranger
things that they were interested in I
mean it seems strange now it seems
strange and embarrassing and awkward but
they really liked South Africa this was
back when it had the apartheid
government that's not to say that they
approved of apartheid or that they were
racists or anything like that but they
were very fond of south of South Africa
and they conservatives would we're
talking about people although pretty far
to the right here they would go there
all the time they would take tours of
the country and South Africa was
propping up its own you know we had our
Contras down in Nicaragua and they had
you know fighting the Sandinista
government down there we were also
supporting the Mujahideen in Afghanistan
who were fighting the Soviets and the
South Africa had their guy in Angola
fighting the government of Angola which
was a Soviet client regime and his name
was Jonas Savimbi and the American right
really liked Jonas Savimbi mckinnon ooze
he's dead now he he managed to keep the
civil war in Angola going basically
single-handedly for 30 years which is an
amazing accomplishment and also a
horrible accomplishment I mean if you
read anything about Angola it's a it's a
disaster land now you know I blew up
dams blew up railroad lines the whole
country is filled with landmines it's it
- just a disaster place and he was South
Africa's contra and they saw him as a
freedom fighter
they called him a freedom fighter yeah
he's back in the news lately if you have
you seen that there's an ad I saw the ad
on TV with with him he was endorsing you
know some laundry deterg-- no no no that
wasn't it it was a he was what happened
was it turns out that one of John
McCain's advisers had been his lobbyist
had been Savimbi's lobbyist back in the
80s and so they're trying to hold that
against McCain so they but that's
neither here nor there yeah the American
right regarded him as a freedom fighter
that's the term that they would use and
they they use the same term to describe
the Contras down in Nicaragua the
Mujahideen in Afghanistan now with the
Mujahideen in Afghanistan that's a
fairly plausible description of them
freedom fighters I mean after all
they're fighting the Soviets right but
they would also apply it to a lot of
really questionable groups there's a
gorilla outfit in Mozambique that they
love to talk about and these guys were
just they were just terrorists they were
bloodthirsty and I think it's after
Savimbi you know after them after
Savimbi's uh you know they're they're
sort of love affair with Savimbi had
faded a little bit it came out that he
was pretty bad dude also but anyhow
during this sort of high period of
Savimbi love Jack Abramoff and his some
of his colleagues put together this
international conference for freedom
fighters in in Jonas Savimbi's camp in
his in his rebel headquarters way out in
in the bush in Angola
out in the middle of nowhere and to get
there they had to get you know go go to
South Africa and be flowing up there by
South African pilots and this sort of
thing and anyhow that's how I got
interested in South Africa but the story
goes on I'm sure you want to hear every
last it's just the long and winding
thing but let me let me make a very long
story short what happened was eventually
Abramoff and his friends started to
think
here in Washington after he'd had this
you know conference of the rebel leaders
in Angola he came back to Washington
started a think tank and he was only at
it for a couple of years but it kept
kept on going after he departed and for
many years it churned out literature and
held conferences and gave out prizes and
did the things that think tanks do and
then it folded what do you know and a
few years after that it was revealed
that this think tank had been a project
of South African military intelligence
and that's that's a very very bizarre
twisted story now this got a lot of
press attention in South Africa so I was
able to do the research on it it got
very little attention here in America
well it's an interesting part of the
book we're gonna take a small break now
and we'll be back in a few minutes
afterwards and several others c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts visit book tv.org more with
Jeanne Cummings and Thomas Frank
presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee Barack Obama has announced
Senator Joe Biden of Delaware as his
vice presidential running mate tonight
at 11:00 Eastern and Sunday at 1:00 p.m.
Eastern on book TV senator Biden's book
promises to keep on life and politics
from last year a personal and political
memoir he discusses the adversities he's
had to work through including the loss
of his first wife and child he also
provides his take on such events as 9/11
and his experiences working in the
Senate under 7 different presidential
administrations Democratic
vice-presidential nominee Senator Joe
Biden on book TV
afterwards with Jeanne Cummings and
Thomas Frank continues and welcome back
we're talking with Tom Frank the offer
author of the wrecking crew how
conservatives rule
now you mentioned all the research you
had done on South Africa for that
section of the book and what struck me
about the book is you have almost a
hundred pages of notes attached to the
back of this book I mean yeah and I just
one word reading Jean you can't get out
of actually I have to admit read the
footnotes some of them are pretty funny
but I just wondered if you if that is
your habit or did you expect challenges
and so you wanted to make darn sure it
was documented or oh it's it's because
of the academic background it's you know
I started doing that in graduate school
and well you you learn to use footnotes
I mean and it's you know it's also a
courtesy to the researchers that come
after you you know they'll want to be
able to look this stuff up and you know
and there will undoubtedly be more books
about Jack Abramoff and people want to
know where to find this stuff but I also
discovered look you can have a lot of
fun with footnotes in addition to that
just putting in the DRI you know it was
in the New York Times on you know July
15th you can you can also put some you
can also use them to go off on on
tangents which I tend to do a lot that's
why in decides now the other thing that
struck me is your your primary villains
are Abramoff Grover Norquist who runs I
wouldn't call him a villain he's an he's
a fascinating man he's a he's a in some
ways a great political genius okay he
he's head of Americans for Tax Reform so
instead of villains I'll use the word
characters yeah your primary characters
are Abramoff and Grover Norquist
and Newt and for mr. Tom DeLay and Tom
DeLay and the current administration
gets a fair amount of play in the book
as well but given the you know two or
three decades that you're documenting
here I thought Reagan and the
first bush administration they got
touches but it I wondered why there
wasn't more emphasis on the leadership
of those administration's as compared to
later I just wondered if because these
guys I mean we're talking about College
Republicans laying the groundwork for
you know a very big philosophy of
conservatism and a in your in your book
and in your thesis a very destructive
approach to government but that seems
highly unlikely yeah they were I
actually wouldn't say they laid the
groundwork I'd say that they exemplified
it okay and I'm interested in them
because well obviously because Abramoff
and Norquist were big players in the
College Republicans but before them
there was a group called the young
Americans for freedom
they're I think they're still around in
some some form the gaff and a lot of my
characters came out of that as well that
was a kind of forerunner of Abramoff's
college Republicans a very conservative
group and that very prominent in the
Reagan administration and well I'm sure
they're in this current administration
as well but these youth groups don't by
themselves you know figure everything
out they're just you you see a lot of
these ideas in their at their most naked
when these guys are kids and are writing
and or they're not kids they're in their
20s you know and they're writing in
their magazines and you know giving
interviews and stuff like that mm-hmm
and but what about Reagan the Reagan
administration in the first Bush
administration did you I wondered if you
found in them something less like did
was there tension with government and
governing less so than what we see in
the current Bush administration was that
your assessment that their anticipate
how to antipathy towards government and
its functioning was it less it wasn't
wasn't as pronounced now I think that
Reagan was Reagan was really the you
know he's the one that really laid the
ground the groundwork for this model
in which you have people from industry
running the regulatory agency that
oversees that that industry that was the
Reagan administration is where you
really started seeing that I mean it had
existed before don't get me wrong
there's examples of this going I mean
going all the way back to the Grover
Cleveland admit there's the most famous
example actually goes back to the Grover
Cleveland administration the Interstate
Commerce Commission which the railroads
you know this it was the first
regulatory body in America the railroads
almost immediately captured it you know
and start mr. funding it with you know
we'd get there man appointed to headed
in this sort of thing of fascinating but
Reagan was really the the mastermind of
this you know putting in people like
James Watt and he was at the Department
of the Interior right and then who was
an EPA and Gorsuch the things that these
names don't really mean anything to
viewers anymore they're but they're
fascinating stories from the 1980s about
about how this stuff was done Reagan
really was the first administration
where this was it was just done on a
massive scale by the way another one of
my favorite examples is from the Nixon
administration Nixon dreamed up a lot of
this but wasn't able to do it
first of all cuz he had you know
Democratic Congress to deal with so
didn't so did Reagan by and large and
then second of all because you know he
was distracted by something called
Watergate you know he couldn't really
put his his whole focus on it but one of
the funnier stories that I unearthed
while I was doing this research was of
the what was it Oh EO the Office of
Economic Opportunity which had been set
up under Lyndon Johnson and this was
going to be the flagship of what they
used to call the war on poverty okay
Nixon gets into office and and he
decides he's going to he's going to
wreck the OEO he is going to destroy
this agency well how is he going to do
it because Congress isn't gonna you know
repeal the law you know Congress has
funded the agency even well he put a guy
in charge of it a very interesting
character and other one of these sort of
conservative geniuses who I'm who I'm
very I find very attractive in a certain
way politically you know I find them
kind of
pugna but as his name was Howard
Phillips anyway he he runs for president
every now and then are the last couple
cycles on a third-party ticket but
President President Nixon put him in as
the acting head of the Office of
Economic Opportunity and the guy
proceeded just to demolish the agency
and he was very open about it would give
interviews to the press about what he
was doing and why and it's a it's a
fascinating story and that's sort of the
that's sort of the earliest incarnation
of this and you know under Bush of
course now you have a Republican
Congress so it's allowed to run you know
it can it can go to its are you I'm
sorry you don't have a Republican
Congress anymore but for a while there
you did and you know here's a point the
people he appointed would get in and
there was nothing to stop them and then
you know there's also the fact that the
the the media itself has really lost the
kind of power that it had in say the age
of Nixon or the age of Reagan you know
when you had the big three networks
remember how Johnson and Nixon would pay
such close attention to what they were
saying
The Washington Post carried a big stick
back in those days
not no more I mean it's you know they
can just brush that off if they feel
like it now and so a lot of things have
changed and it's allowed them to allow
them to really to just to roll this
model out to a maximum extent now the
premise that we have to take through
your book is that government can work
and that they've wrecked it but that
there were I you know moments of you
know government at its best you cite
some periods near the New Deal and the
60s but is that a little nostalgic I
mean do I am there you go but but I mean
there there are plenty who would say
look you know the Conservatives aren't
really wrecking the government the
government itself is unwieldy it's
complex in its duplicate 'iv and and it
really isn't you know the answer yeah
they would they would say that it is the
nature of government to fail
so what happened after Hurricane Katrina
they'd say is it's not that government
dropped the ball it's the government
always drops the ball this is you know
this is why you've got to privatize
everything let Walmart handle it because
government can't do it I think that's
baloney I'm sorry Jane I uh it's okay
I'm doing a little devil's advocate here
no I just I mean you're such a nice
person I don't I don't want to uh I'm
not this is my I'm not good at TV
exactly I'm sorry viewers I'm not you
know doing fine government can work you
know this is this is as you said this is
absolutely essential to to what I
believe it's the basic premise of what
I'm of what I write about and there are
also countless examples of government
working whether we're talking about back
in the third well most of the ones that
I use are back in the 30s but for God's
sakes the government did win World War
two give you an example well it
certainly seems that Katrina was an
extraordinarily bad moment for the Bush
administration in part because FEMA did
work and there were examples of FEMA has
a functioning a very successful because
it had worked previously yeah that's
right and and and it had been
highlighted for that reason and so
people were aware wish himself had
praised it do you remember that and the
in the debate one of the debates with Al
Gore Bush had singled out FEMA as one of
the agencies of the government that
really did its job right yes now no more
mm-hmm
one more devil's advocate here the
conservatives will counter with examples
of left-leaning government still in
place at say the city level Newt
Gingrich this book talks about Detroit
and the you know describes a government
that is you know as I said complexity
duplicitous or slaving to the unions and
not functioning yeah so you know there's
there's this sort of tit-for-tat that
can go on well that's not much of a
comparison come on the the city
government of Detroit compared to the
federal government I mean I I don't live
in Detroit and I don't I mean I
heard about the scandals but the you
know the guy got caught that was
actually a very amusing scandal I'm sort
of a collector of scandals and that was
that one was particularly amusing and
look I lived in Chicago for many years I
this this sort of a you know urban urban
myths government is commonplace I come
from Kansas City we had the most up
until the 1940s that I mean though
probably the most corrupt municipal
government of all times
this boss Pendergast he used to boast
about to the to the press he would boast
about what he did and how he did it you
know it was it was amazing I think that
municipal government is probably in a
separate category I mean it's
structurally different from from what
I'm talking about
and I'm not you know in any way I'm not
gonna deny that any of that stuff goes
on of course I'm not denying it but at
the same time I'm not an authority on I
can't talk about it I but I would say
that it is it is a completely different
question than what we're talking about
here in Washington okay now another
theme in the book is defunding the Left
which is it you know you could probably
write a whole book about that it's a
great slogan as well and and it's a
really interesting tactic yeah um and
but I wondered if we look at modern at
our moment now the left looks so
financially yeah yeah that's right
well Obama looks healthy he does look
healthy but if you look at the last
cycle the Senate committee out raised
the congressional committee out raised
the democratic committee out raised the
Republican committees by substantial
amount of amounts but g'd they aren't
the left aren't the left
no they're there I mean they're more
liberal than the Republicans but the
Democratic Party itself has been pulled
by the gravity of money to to the right
since the well since the 1960s
certainly you know the this is one of
the the things that marked them in the
1980s is that they decided to start
imitating Republican methods in
fundraising catering to business there
are there's more than one Democratic
leader right now in Washington
that has his own version of the K Street
project or they I mean a sort of
watered-down version of the K Street
project which was you know the notorious
sort of Tom DeLay forgotten his name
Grover Norquist's idea that they would
that they would move the lobbying
industry to the right via the Republican
Congress yeah there's a but I wouldn't I
wouldn't call them the left I'd call
them the Democrats and yes they they
look very healthy right now defund the
left to get back to the original point I
actually have back at home a lapel pin
that says defund the left and this was
again the brainchild of one of these
sort of conservative geniuses that I
like to write about I mentioned him
already Howard Phillips he was the one
that that popularized that slogan I
don't know whether he invented it or not
and his idea was that you that the
federal government was was funding the
left through all these sort of programs
that people think of as being very
benign you know the Department of
Education the Environmental Protection
Agency Legal Services Corporation that
the money that they were spending was
effectively going into the pockets of
people who then turn around and give it
to liberals you know or people who are
very left-wing or something like that
and so we've got to cut off these
organizations stop that spending and you
will you will wreck the left in this
country okay and that was you know he
was sort of the the one that was
identified at this idea in the 80s but
it really is Grover Norquist and and the
the big thinkers of the Gingrich delay
Congress who really took this idea to
its to its logical conclusion you know
identifying the various institutions
that support the Democratic Party or
that dragged the Democratic Party to the
left trial lawyers labor unions I'm
forgetting the others but they've you
know there's a list a list of them and
the idea is one by one systematically
attack these organizations or at least
attack their avenues through which they
they get money to the Democratic Party
and that's been very successful I mean
the the things that the war that they've
waged on trial lawyers they you know
there's been all sorts of waves of tort
reform you look at what they've done
it'll
movement I mean they have crushed it
what is the what is the unionization
rate in the private sector now it's
something like 7% down from 35% back in
the 1950s you know that's that is
extraordinary now they haven't only
defunded the left they've also I mean
dramatically changed the you know social
map of our country by doing that by
wrecking the labor movement you know but
that's it that's a story well we'll come
to that later but in some ways yeah it
looked like a dramatic success story but
as you say now here's Obama raising
these you know enormous amounts of money
should I keep going on this I mean
because it's not it's not just such a
simple question well think of who he
gets his money from you know but but do
you classify Obama as just a Democrat or
do you think there that he is it does he
represent a rebirth of the lap of
liberalism Oh golly it would be it would
be nice if he did I mean it would be
great if he did if he did I'd be like
the most enthusiastic Obama supporter
ever
I shouldn't say things like that my my
candidate was John Edwards I thought he
was a genuine liberal you know in the
old in the old school manner with the
two Americas yeah but he was also he was
really focusing on poverty and a lot of
the issues that that really who we
should be debating you know the the the
the divide between workers and
management in this country you want to
hear a astonishing fact the the the guy
who earned the most money in America
last year there was some hedge fund
manager that earned three billion
dollars last year when I was born in
1965 the richest man in the world
was worth about one and a half billion
dollars it's that's how much that's how
this country has changed and we should
be debating that we should be saying
what the hell has happened to us you
know and at the same time you know wages
are stagnant I mean there's these
stories in the newspaper now about this
meat packing plant in Iowa that's
apparent
been using child labor you know crazy
things are going on this country is for
working people this country is going in
Reverse
that's what liberals need to be debating
Obama I think his heart is probably in
the right place he hasn't so far shown
any that much willingness to take these
issues on I wish he would I wish he
would you know confront the Bush
administration on some of these things
because they really are responsible for
it now the Democratic Party is it tries
to remake itself as the model they're
using is the Republican machinery some
of which you talk about and some of it
some of which isn't in your book but is
more internal party infrastructure but
is that a mistake well it depends on
what particular thing you're talking
about the what what fascinates I mean
the internal machinery of the parties is
not a subject that I'm all that familiar
with what intrigues me about
conservatism is this fixation they have
with answering to the market okay and my
argument of course is that when you turn
market forces when you on government and
on politics and when a politician
becomes an entrepreneur you know and is
selling himself to the highest bidder
whether illegally through through bribes
and we have seen some of that in recent
years here in Washington or in legally
you know and there's a million ways that
they can do it whether it's you know
having these uh fundraisers or golf
weekends or you know whatever it is that
they do that that's not democracy
that's plutocracy that is ruled by an
oligarchy of the very wealthy and I
would be very sorry indeed to see the
Democratic Party adopt that idea of you
know answering to the market answering
to the needs of money that's it's
repulsive to me and you suggest that
that the Clinton administration to a
certain level did embrace that yeah they
did you know much you know I I was not a
big fan of Bill Clinton and I one of my
earlier books I described my my
disillusionment with him in at great
length
as I am want to do but you know compared
to Bush he really it's he looks pretty
good respect and for my from my from
where I said but some of the things that
Clinton did we're pretty awful one of
them in my opinion was NAFTA and that
yes he was answering to the needs of
money when when when they when they when
they did that you know free trade
agreement with with with Mexico and
Canada but more particularly the Clinton
administration seemed to be infatuated
with the idea of entrepreneurial
government I think this is a term do you
remember that book that they loved the
Clinton all the Clinton people loved
back in 1992 it was called reinventing
government and that was the whole idea
was you would bring yep no no that no
Clinton didn't write it no no but they
the whole idea was that you would bring
entrepreneurial forces to play on
government and you would I mean there's
these passages in there about how you
know outsourcing and privatizing is the
most wonderful thing they compared it
when you when you when you get rid of a
bureaucrat you know you turn his job
over the private sector hopefully he
gets the job in the private sector he
gets to go with it but when you do that
you are setting him free you're
liberating him they compared to being
born again you know this kind of really
religious terms you know and so yeah the
Clinton people really embraced the the
ideology of market forces and government
marketized government and that's a
terrible has turned out to have terrible
you know catastrophic consequences for
the rest of us it would have been should
I shot a shut up here
it would have been in my opinion better
if they had you know pushed back at what
some of the things that Reagan had done
reversed some of those things rather
than saying oh you know the accepting
them you know two-thirds of the way
which is what they did because that just
allowed the then the succeeding
president george w bush to just push it
that much farther and gave him incentive
to do it too you know now so I guess
that that raises the question that I
kind of wondered when I finished your
book you're close with it's time to
the Conservatives accountable that for
what how they have governed and and the
condition of the government as they
close the Bush years but the question is
what if not embracing the market what is
the philosophy you think that should be
adopted and what is the alternative mmm
what's my philosophy of government I
would hate you is I would say democracy
I would say yeah and I would say
democracy not only in terms of one man
one vote one person one vote excuse me
but also in terms of society I mean look
at the America that we have become
compared to the America that we were in
say in the 1960s or the 1970s when I
mean back when I was a kid there was
nothing strange about a blue-collar
person living in a suburb right next
door to a white-collar person that sort
of thing happened all the time
now that's unthinkable I mean the
white-collar people live in these you
know castles out in McClane or whatever
you know it looks like Versailles or
something like that and then and the
blue-collar people are struggling from
paycheck to paycheck and that's the
America that we have become and in my
mind that's not that is that is a huge
step in the wrong direction and you know
what else it is it's not conservative
these people have not conserved that
society that they were born into that
society that we grew up in that sort of
middle class America they've wrecked it
there's a book that came out a few years
ago that was very influential to me it
was called I'm sorry I haven't thought
about it for a while but it was called a
brief history of neoliberalism it's by a
professor called David Harvey and he
asked neoliberal is he's British
neoliberalism is the term that they use
over there to describe what we would
call conservatism they say fair let the
market do it they call that
neoliberalism you know turning
everything over to the market
worshipping the market and he says he
looks back at the long history of
neoliberalism you know thirty years or
whatever and he says
has this project the neoliberal project
has it been a utopian project by which
he means you know let the have this sort
of free-market utopian which everything
is wonderful and you know the free
market solves all our problems which a
lot of these guys will tell you that's
what they're doing that's what they
believe in
you know the libertarians they talk that
way all the time has it been a utopian
project or has it been a class project
to restore class power and although it's
always they always use their utopian
rhetoric you know we're gonna have free
choice and you know everything is going
to be great and rational choice rational
expectations and all that what they
actually do when they have the power is
the class project restore the power of
the ruling class you know bring back the
power of those people used to have in
the 1920s in the 1930s and that they
lost courtesy of liberalism so if the
Left were to regain power how do you
then undo I mean you talk about damage
so you talk about wage gaps you talk
about hiring incompetence yeah do you
just hire competent people and pay them
better and we're you know we're on our
way or how bad is the damage and do you
believe and how would someone then turn
it around that's that is the you know
that's the big question and I don't
think it can be turned around very
easily because so much of the government
has been outsourced and so many of the
best minds and you know most talented
people have left or don't consider
government as a career option that it's
it's going to be very hard to rebuild it
and you know I interviewed career civil
servants who would talk about this and I
say that you know the whole place has
been hollowed out you have to start over
again at basically at square one you
have to do what Roosevelt did back in
1933 and recruit you know an army of
talented and enthusiastic young people
motivated hopefully by patriotism to
come to the capital and and and get this
thing working again but you also have to
you have to investigate why you know
what went wrong over the preceding
three decades and one of the things I'm
trying to the point I'm trying to make I
didn't say it in the book but I'm trying
to say it every time I do a reading or
you know go on a TV show or talk on the
radio or whatever it is is that the
first thing President Obama should do
when he's when he's in office after he's
sworn in this he should appoint a
commission to investigate privatization
and outsourcing of the government
because the we don't really know what's
happened one of the most frustrating
things about the you know wave of
privatization and outsourcing is that
there's very little accountability you
know you can try picking up the phone
and calling Blackwater for example you
know the the outfit that we've got
toting guns around in Iraq and you can
ask them why they do the things that
they do and they're not going to tell
you because they don't answer to we the
people they answer to their boss they
are a private company and so when you
put this stuff in the you know when you
when you export federal operations into
the private sector it it's no longer you
know it's no longer that easy to hold
these people accountable it disappears
into that you know that world where they
don't have to take your phone call they
don't even have to take your
congressman's phone call and even more
fascinating there's all sorts of you
know offices throughout the federal
government that are supposed to
scrutinize outsourcing and keep an eye
on this stuff and conservatives have
persistently tried to shut those offices
down so that there is no accountability
and there is no scrutiny so we don't
really know and so one of the first
things that President Obama of course if
he gets in what he has to do is appoint
a commission that's going to look at in
close detail the last 30 years of the
you know marketized government and say
is it really everything we thought it
was going to be didn't really save us
money did it really you know do things
more efficiently did it really allow you
know bureaucrats to be born again you
know all that sort of thing we need to
look into this and see if you know if
this is really the way we want to
continue to proceed and you know I can
tell you what the answer is going to be
if you maybe I'll wait for the report
yeah we'll do that in the next the next
show thank you so much tom
joining us today